i won't help you  but  small things  no the problem is black can always  force a draw  whenever he wants he doesn't have to  obviously but  he could yeah so yeah they got this rock  ending where unusually fall down  okay winning chances are limited  i guess they will repeat because wesley  is a gentleman rook two five king h6  rookie five he doesn't need this victory  draw was sufficient yeah  yeah i don't know if that was a move  repetition or resignation  was a move repetition  that was a move repetition and uh game  has ended in draw and that means only  one thing that wesley  has won the armageddon game  and takes one and a half points  anish  well he does have the commission  commemoration prize of winning one  it's not point  much in it though